[Music]
we haven't been intimated in probably
five or six years we kind of stopped
holding hands three or four years ago
why for five years
have you never brought up to your wife
hey we haven't had sex in
1500 days good gosh this is a lot okay
[Music]
hey uh what's happening this is john
with the dr john dolone's show
let's roll up our sleeves and get after
it we're talking about mental health
relationships
education your kids whatever's going on
in your world your marriages
hope you're doing well hope things are
going all right wherever you happen to
be if you want to be on the show give me
a shout at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com
ask and james is on vacation
so we got ben the man kelly
even jenna jenna got moved up front row
front row joe it's awesome to see you
there all right let's go to david in
clearfield utah what's up brother d
hey john you can hear me okay yeah
absolutely what's up man
um so i got into a
i guess a texting argument with um one
of my wife's family members
who i'm fairly close with um
basically
i was trying to figure out what was
going on and
he told me
in a nutshell that i'm super
argumentative i turn everything into a
competition and even went as far as to
say is like i'm emotionally abusive
toward my wife
and so
i kind of sat down and had a
conversation with my wife about it and
she i basically asked i said you know is
that true am i like that and she said
not all the time but yeah
and um
she said that she doesn't feel like i'm
emotionally abusive because she's been
in those relationships before
but she does she did say that like i do
things that are hurtful and and i raise
my voice a lot and stuff like that
um
i've had i've been told this before by
other people in my past so i know it's
true
but i'm not
sure how i can be i guess more
self-aware self-aware of
how i'm talking and how i'm behaving
hmm
man that's hard to hear
yeah
um first first i would man recommend
strongly
never ever ever get into text fights
with anybody
nothing no one ever wins there because
you miss so much of the um
body language and body posture and
people say they lob grenades via text
that they wouldn't in person so
um but anyway we're here now um what led
to the fight
um
i just had
i felt like things were getting really
tense between us and i wasn't sure why
and so i just kind of
i had texted him because we had been
texting and i just basically said hey
you know i don't know what's been going
on lately you seem like you've been more
upset with me lately you know
if i've done something you know just
tell me i'll try to make it right and
stuff
but this didn't come out of the blue
something happened what happened
um
just
i guess just
[Music]
i don't know a lot of just
we kind of banter back and forth we'll
joke with each other but lately it's
been like really hurtful and like really
mean things
um that you're saying to him are you
saying to you
that he's been saying to me and i i
thought maybe i was making it up a
little bit but then my wife started to
notice it too and she brought it up yeah
and so i was like okay maybe i should
try to air out the laundry here a little
bit and figure out what's going on okay
um so a couple things here one is
it feels like your wife well number one
good for
your brother-in-law because he doesn't
like the way
some guy is treating his sister right so
i'm glad he said i wish he'd come up and
directly said something to you instead
of
being passive-aggressive and throwing
little
cheap jabs here and there i wish you'd
come up and
had a direct confrontation with you not
in a fistfight kind of way but in a hey
don't talk to my sister like this or why
are you i'm struggling you said you're
really close to him and so you you
deserve that conversation that he didn't
have but
it's out there now
it also sounds like your sister
has not felt safe talking to you about
stuff but has circled around and gone
and talked to her brother about you
um how did that conversation go with
your wife like she confirmed some of the
stuff he said
and she tried to soften it a little bit
because she's got to live with you he
doesn't
um
what was the nature of that conversation
did she feel
was there a relief that she finally get
to say this stuff out loud was there a
sense of
trepidation she was nervous to tell you
stuff
i don't i don't know if she was nervous
um we had had kind of this conversation
before earlier in our relationship
and i i thought that i had been doing
better because it hadn't come up in a
long time but then it obviously it
ruined its ugly head again
um but i felt like the conversation
actually went really well it really
started a healthy conversation and so
i've been trying to do things to work on
you know myself but okay i felt like the
nature of the conversation was actually
really good okay
so whenever we say things like
overbearing or emotionally abusive or
too competitive um
those
those are grenade words not helpful to
me
so be specific you said you know what
your brother-in-law said is true and
what your wife said is true so give me
some examples where are you
competitive to the point that you know
you're crossing a line
well that's kind of my issue is i don't
know and i asked my wife i asked her i
said you know can you give me a specific
example of the time i've been too
competitive and i haven't really been
able to get a clear answer on that all
right so let's dig in when somebody's
got a like a story or a one time i did
this are you a guy that goes oh yeah
well one time i is that you
um are you a one-upper
i don't know
yes you might probably
i mean you know
like can somebody tell a story about the
scariest time they almost got a car
wreck and you just sit there in silence
or do you have to say oh yeah one time i
got a car wreck yes or no i probably i
probably do that yeah okay do you do you
talk about money who's making what at
family events
you ask your brother how much you know i
i
no i try not to talk money i don't like
those conversations well where do you
where else would you somebody else might
consider you competitive
are you like uh meet the [ __ ] or do
you like get crazy at uh at volleyball
games you know what i mean family
volleyball games or whatever like
where's this competitive thing coming up
with sports i think i'm fairly
competitive okay i'm like like we went
bowling together and i was having a good
game i was getting really excited and i
wasn't trying to be mean about it you
know and i was trying to like cheer
everybody else on too but i i can see
where like in that situation i probably
was pretty overbearing
okay so be specific what is you know
kind of probably pretty overbearing what
like be specific were you yelling at
people or you like suck it were like in
people's faces pouring beer on them like
what were you
doing just just being loud and kind of
rambunctious um
clearly and nobody else was
um yeah i think that's fair okay all
right
um what about
emotionally abusive
your wife confirmed that she said i
wouldn't call you abusive but yeah you
go too far
you said you raised your voice are you
someone who yells a lot
um yeah i have kind of a loud
personality okay and
that's the thing that kind of worries me
the most i think is because like
i'm not i'm not being mean
i guess when i raise my voice but
it comes across mean
okay um i'm easily excited so any
regardless of the mood or anything i'll
raise my voice it's just
something i've always done i guess so
hear me say that yelling at somebody and
anger is abuse
so if you get mad if you get angry you
get frustrated and you start yelling
yell at your wife you your house yield
your brother-in-law you yell in the
house at somebody and your wife's
sitting there
if you've got little kids in the house
and you're yelling
that's trauma that hurts people
if you're just a loud guy and
this is the pot talking of the kettle
here i'm a loud guy too
here's what was an important um
shape-shifting moment for me
that
my intention
often doesn't matter
that if i want to really love people
especially my wife but if i want to love
my friends if i want to love my
community if i want to love ben and
kelly and everybody in the in the booth
then i'm responsible for making sure i
can be heard and making sure i'm a safe
place to be around and most that goes
it's very counter-cultural to talk like
that because the culture says you just
be you bro and everybody can adjust
that's stupid
if i if i am too much
then the world will respond by leaving
me completely alone
and so i value relationships and other
people's feelings safe around me and so
i work hard to bring it down a notch and
bring it down a notch for me is bringing
it down many notches for most people
because i'm a lot right
um
there's something here
if i can be honest with you i don't like
how you're being kind of aloof
like i don't know man i guess it's just
maybe
like you've got two people who love you
and that you love in your life telling
you that you hurt them
and you say yeah i believe them but i
don't
know man i'm not buying it
i don't know if it's a protective thing
you set up or just kind of a way you get
through life
be honest with me man
i
i'm just not very self-aware i guess i i
don't know
i know you don't want me to be a loose
and i'm not trying to be i just i don't
know what the actual issue is and why i
tend to
i guess get loud in certain situations
or to get competitive or argumentative i
don't know okay
so one of the greatest gifts a person in
your situation can have and i've been
there too most people have where they're
being a certain way they're acting a
certain way and they
they don't have a full grasp on it
one of the greatest gifts you can have
is people that you trust in your life to
be honest with you
and so here's your homework assignment
you ready
it is to
number one create a written dialogue
with your wife
either
she's not able to come up with with
answers really fast
and she wants to be more thoughtful in
her answers or she just comes to answers
a little bit more organically a little
more slowly her answers are more thought
through or she doesn't feel safe
speaking them out loud
often in that situation people will
write them down
or
offer to
say hey i'd love to go to a marriage
counsel i want to be better at this and
i'm i'm i'm i've created a world where
you don't feel safe and it makes me sick
to my stomach that i'm doing that to the
one person who i love more than anybody
else
would you go talk to somebody with me
um and let her
a therapist's job is to create a safe
environment for people to have hard
conversations
and so hopefully so a neutral third
party would be able to create that
environment where she could then speak
um have you ever been aggressive with
her
um as far as
physically or just verbally both
um i've never laid a hand on her like
ever okay um
um i've never
i've never cuffed at her i've never
we've never gotten like a screaming
match like we've had arguments but we've
never like screamed at each other or
anything like that all right
um and so the next thing you do is i
want you to have a conversation with
your brother-in-law in person tell them
hey i want to go out for drinks when i
go for coffee whatever i'm buying
um
i need some help start that way i need
some help
and i would tell him hey number one
sorry for doing this over text i should
never have texted you this stuff in the
first place i should have just met with
you in person i'm sorry
number two
your sister means the absolute world to
me i love her more than anything else
and it hurts to find out from
somebody i respect and i love too
that you feel like i'm abusive that i'm
too competitive i'm hard to be around
will you help me
because i don't see it and it really
needs some clarity in my life
um that sort of humility is going to
open you up
and i want you to take a pen and
something to write on when he's talking
and write that stuff down and like you
did with your wife acid can you give me
this example man
and
if he's right all right let me put it
this way this isn't the conversation to
go yeah but this is a conversation for
you just to listen and maybe you tell
them that i'm not going to refute
anything you say today i just want to
listen
i'm about healing this and i clearly
have some work i need to do on me and i
need somebody that i trust to help me be
reflective because i'm missing it
and hopefully he's the person of
integrity and you'll have that
conversation do you think you will
yeah i definitely think okay
and then the third one so you got your
wife you got your brother-in-law those
are the two have been involved here do
you have a
mentor a boss that you trust or a team
leader at your office that you trust or
a couple of friends that you've known
for a long time that you trust
uh i do have a friend that i could reach
out to i would love for you to reach out
and say hey all right here's hard
conversation
i've gotten some feedback from some
folks in my life that i love my wife and
that i'm too much
that i'm overbearing i'm overly
competitive i'm even like one of them
called me emotionally abusive like i
need you to be honest with me and i've
had this conversation with friends of
mine in the past trevor craig todd kevin
michael i've i can name the men in my
life who i've gone to john dewell i've
talked to folks
and um have asked for some direct
feedback and
it was really hard to hear in certain
seasons in my life and it was a great
great gift
um your friends might lie to you and be
like nah bro no no no like it's all good
forget them screw that guy hopefully
they'll be honest like yeah dude you
know it and here's the thing my buddies
when i've asked for feedback or hey i'm
struggling with this am i not seeing
this right
um
dude
they're like are you serious
how do you not know that every time we
play a game everybody gets out of the
way because you're you know what i mean
or whatever the thing would be with you
but they're real direct with me real
direct and it's changed my life and so
at this point if you can honestly look
in the mirror and say
i believe they're telling the truth but
i don't see it then your job is to go
with people who will be reflective with
you and will tell you the truth and your
job isn't to fight it or refute it it's
to lean into it um and then here's what
we're gonna do you're gonna have a pile
of information when you get done all
right david you're gonna have a bunch of
stuff here like this and then that and
then that
then you're gonna be about working on it
so i'm gonna do you a favor i'm gonna
give you a copy of own your past change
your futures my new book coming out i'm
gonna give you a copy of it because it's
gonna walk you through what do you do
next
one of the cornerstones of that book is
you have to own reality i didn't want
this but here's what i where i am either
what i'm doing what's been done to me
here's where i am
and what the heck do i do now and so it
will walk you out so hang on the line
i'll send you a copy of it um
and then you might need to call somebody
you might need to call somebody when you
reach out to betterhelp and they pump it
into your house for therapy or you reach
out to a local therapist in your
community you may need to sit down and
say i've got a long history of this
behavior my guess is
um
you getting loud is a way to keep people
off of you it's a distance it's a
protective measure your overly
competitiveness
is because somebody told you somewhere
that you don't
have a lot of value unless you're in
first place
and you have created value for yourself
by being allowed by being the guy and
all the stuff and i win
your face
and your way you protect yourself ends
up let me say like the way you have
developed coping mechanism mechanisms to
take care of yourself
you end up
forcing people away from you which just
reinforces your coping mechanism so you
get louder and louder and louder and
then people get further and further away
from you until one or two of them
finally snaps like your brother-in-law
did
so what you're gonna have to do is learn
new coping mechanisms and usually coping
mechanisms start with you looking in the
mirror and saying i'm worth something
better than this i'm worth something
more than this
because i'm tired of being loud i'm
tired of being the guy's got to be all
i'm tired of being that guy
i want to be able to just sit and hold
my wife's hand i want to be quiet i want
to be loved i still like laughing i
still have been silly i still like being
you know the bell the ball but
i'm worth more than this
so give it a shot brother give it a shot
we'll be in your corner write me i want
you to reach back out to us let me know
how that call went with your
brother-in-law with that conversation
you're gonna have that that in person
let me know how that goes and we'll
feature you back on the show cause
people are gonna be wondering what that
conversation is like and what the
follow-up is and i'll keep walking
alongside you that's my commitment we'll
be right back
do you want a better life a better
marriage better mental and physical
health
the single most important action you can
take to improve your mental and physical
health to change your entire life
is to get enough deep restorative
quality sleep i know this from research
and as a guy who has struggled with
sleep for my entire life and for me good
sleep starts with a world-class mattress
that's why my family sleeps on dream
cloud mattress dream cloud is advanced
technology and you can buy it in the
store or you can do it like i did and
have it shipped directly to your house
dreamcloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for dr john
daloni show listeners 399 bucks and
accessories plus an additional 250
discount that's a total of 649
in accessories and savings pillows
mattress protectors luxury sheets all of
it it's time to stop sleeping on your
old college mattress or the old me down
from grandma and start changing your
life visit dreamcloudsleep.com deloney
or dreamcloudsleep and enter promo code
deloney and get your new mattress
today all right we are back let's go to
sarah with an h in dallas texas what's
up sarah
hi dr john how are you
i'm doing well how are you
we are having a party that's not true
we're not having a party at all we're
hanging out we're just we're working
we're working having fun so what's up
love it
so i am little back story um i'm 36
years old and uh going on 37 this summer
and single
have had a pretty horrible dating
experience the past few years and
have been thinking um
more recently in the past year or so
about how i do
want a family and
taking the age into consideration
and
just my history
what with dating
that it could possibly be something that
i
would want to do or kind of end up doing
on my own
in terms of having a child and
i've been looking into fertility options
and potentially considering
a sperm donor
and now really just looking at all the
questions that come along with that um
both for myself and
you know how do i personally deal with
that how do i deal with questions that
would come up if i do go this route and
then also
if
i did go that route and had a child what
that looks like for the child and how
how to
talk about that with a young a young kid
is it even smart to
have a child without a father so
i just have a lot of
questions and
things to come up to consider
just
i'm just going to throw i'm just going
to throw a light softball at you and see
uh good gosh this is a lot okay real
quick what me what happened to your
dating thing what was so bad about that
and there's a reason why i'm asking that
question we'll circle back to it but
what happened in your in that was
terrible in your dating life
uh so i had a kind of traumatic um
first date dating situation about eight
years ago and i've been in therapy we
assaulted you
yeah okay yeah i'm so sorry
i'm sorry i think
yeah
so that happened eight years ago and you
were in your late 20s
and
that has rippled
through every relationship or attempted
relationship since
exactly okay
what about before then
before then i
it wasn't as
horrible
i had i had
a handful of good dating experiences um
a few
mid long-term relationships that
that
ended they didn't work out but it was
there was respect involved and mutual
respect and understanding just normal
dating relationships they were fine they
ended in breakups but just was what it
was right okay yeah yeah
okay so on the front end of this call
i'm gonna let you know that a i'm not an
expert here and i've got
some experience i've i had a super close
friend and she had two extraordinary
kids via sperm donor um and so that's my
that's my personal experience here
um i do have some broader conversations
i want to have with you and i want you
to know that i'm not gonna
i am intentionally trying to walk
alongside you so if i say something the
wrong way if i say something that comes
across like i'm against you please hear
me say that's not what i'm trying to do
okay
um all right so
that my first red flag here is how hard
it was for you to
get right to the point and say i'm
thinking about having a kid with a sperm
donor
and
that the reason that's a red flag for me
is
you
you sound hurt
and anytime somebody makes a
truly life-altering forever altering
decision out of hurt
it usually comes with a
it comes with
systemic challenges both in the present
and down the road
and so the first thing i think is
important for you to do
is to exhale for a minute and this is
going to be brutal and hard but you have
to grieve the picture of what you
thought your life at 37 was gonna look
like
because it doesn't
and
i would get really really specific with
that grief
i thought i would have three kids by now
i thought i'd be some highfalutin lawyer
in downtown dallas and i thought i'd
married some guy who was had most of his
hair at least for crying out loud right
i think getting really specific i
thought we'd live in this neighborhood i
wanted to be here
i think really specific about that grief
because what's going to happen is you're
going to be hurting in different areas
and your
body and your brain are going to
continue to be solving for that picture
there's going to continue to be a gap
between reality and what your body's
trying to solve for
and so you're going to stuff a bunch of
stuff down in that gap potentially a new
child
or a new picture of family without fully
grieving what what isn't
and the challenge you've heard me say
this on the show a lot is the hardest
thing about new stuff
new adventures new boyfriends new
husbands new homes new kids new whatever
is that you go with you
and a new kid isn't going to
take away hurt
you hear what i'm saying
i do and i know that's hard to hear out
loud and so i'm trying to say it in the
most i'm saying it with you right like
i'm on your side of the booth here at
the bar okay
but
it's it won't fill that hole
um
what type of
what type of trauma healing have you
done over the last eight years have you
been in and out of counseling
i just started therapy
going on a year and a half ago okay
how's that going
um it's been going well um
in the beginning we used the emdr
technique
and
um
i'd say probably over the past three
months so i feel like i've hit a little
bit of
um
maybe like a little bit of a wall where
i
i
just get a sense that i'm
talking about the same things and
and coming to a point where i feel like
i'm repeating the same things and it's
are you ready to be done with that story
yeah
it's still really close
and what i mean by that is when you when
i just mentioned it a second ago your
body took off on you again didn't it
it's real close to the surface
and so that tells me for the last 18
months you've talked about it a lot
and you may have and you've done some
done some some
hacks and some you know some techniques
and emdr is incredible
but the next layer below that is a
choice too i'm not going to carry i'm
not going to give this person any more
access to my life anymore and so i'm
gonna start working at that level
and why that's hard is your body says no
we have to keep this thing top of mind
so this hurt never happens again
and you have to go into therapy and say
okay i'm ready to be done with this
story
let's get there
tired of talking about it what are the
action steps i can take
you hear what i'm saying
yeah and that's scary as bloody hell
right
yeah and i like to have answers and i
feel like i don't know
okay how to get there yeah a
it may be time to see a new counselor
and that sucks because that means you
have to tell the whole story over again
you got to go through all this stuff
again but letting somebody who's a
world-class therapist in your community
letting them know hey here's where i've
been and i'm ready to take the next step
and be done with this and now that
you're ever going to be done with it but
i want to be able to remember what
happened and not cry and not have that
be the top of mind i want to be able to
remember what happened and not all of a
sudden my hands are sopping wet and my
heart's racing on me i want to be able
to
tell somebody what happened because i'm
going to meet somebody i'm going to tell
that person hey this happened one time
and or i'm gonna drive through that
neighborhood and my body's gonna start
screaming on me that's what healing
looks like nothing you forget not that
you're still not pissed off not all that
but it means that your body goes oh no
we're okay now we weren't then but we're
okay now
that's what we're aiming for
okay
so that's an aside here let's get back
to this question you asked me
um the way i see it done
and before i mean i gotta say like she's
a close family friend and she's a
brilliant scholar and um i didn't call
her before here this this call so i i
don't want to use her name here but
here's how i saw her approach it and her
kids were incredible they played with my
kids they were awesome
she was real open with him i mean it was
as open as open could be
i i chose you
i went to a place and i chose you
and
um
was definitely challenges with only
having one parent in the house i mean
single being a single parent is tough
and all the data will will bridge that
out and so
i think that's a separate phone call for
me and you to have some day
um but yeah it's hard being a single
parent it's really hard it just is
um both financially both
emotionally but psychologically both
just having some people in your life to
help carry that load it's hard
millions and millions people do it and
millions do it well right
um but it's hard but
man she just was pretty direct her kids
knew that um they came from a donor and
they had some info on them
here's what's happened over the last
decade is technology has improved
something dramatic
and now the conversation is people
starting to meet up on facebook groups
hey did you have donor xyz abcd one two
three four
and now the ethical issues are popping
up because
kids young people who are now growing up
to be teenagers and young adults
and even adults are able to bypass the
original um donor facility and find each
other and they're finding they have many
many many half brothers and half sisters
and what do i do with that and do i owe
them money or am i supposed to meet with
them do they come to my family reunions
and now there's just a broader
messier much more complex situation than
a closed-loop system where i had a sperm
donor nobody knows who that's in a
file folder somewhere and this is just
my new life
it just opens it up to a web a complex
web okay like with dna genetic testing
and all those kind of things
um have you thought about egg embryo
adoption
no i haven't looked uh so much into that
okay that's another
just thing to think about um couples who
are going through ivf will freeze
certain number of uh
eggs fertilized eggs and then all sudden
they'll have twins and then they'll go
again they'll have twins on four kids
and they're still four or five
fertilized embryos out there and so
there's a process now where people are
beginning to adopt fertilized images you
go through the whole process
the challenge there is half of it isn't
yours um genetically speaking right you
still go through the whole pregnancy
process so all i have to say is there's
a bunch of options if you want to go
down that road um i would meet with
somebody who's been down that road have
you talked to somebody who's
who's been
has gotten pregnant by a donor
i haven't i have two friends that have
friends so
i'm kind of in the early stages i love
it i love it love it and the further
down the road i got i would definitely
want to talk to them about i love it
what's your what's your hang up on it
what are you nervous about
um
i think
for me it's more about the child
and
and
them going through life with questions
of you know who
you know why they were chosen like this
who their father is you know do they
ever find him do they find half brothers
and sisters those sorts of things and
and what kind of
psychological impact that would have on
i've seen a movement in the adoption
world towards more open adoptions
because there's we're getting less and
less such thing as a closed adoption
um because the technology is allowing
people to find each other so i think
down the road yes there will be the
ability for your child to find donor
father
donor dad
there will be an ability to find
half siblings all over planet earth like
those that will be built into the system
what i can't do with any sort of
integrity is speak to the i don't i
don't have any data i don't know of any
data um on the psychological
wherewith i mean the psychological
well-being of kids who i mean we're just
on the this technology is just
relatively i mean we're just a couple
generations into this technology
and so i i don't have any data on that i
think your best bet would be to sit down
and talk with people who have
experienced it have walked through it
um what is their experience with their
kids what are the hard questions their
kids ask and by the way all kids ask
hard questions all of them do
and um there is a
i've heard about i've read a little bit
about but not enough to be
statistically sure of myself about
kids who have um been adopted have this
what they call an original heartache um
that that that question that haunts them
what was so bad about me that my parents
didn't keep me and
one of the things i've heard over and
over from folks who've adopted is
they're continually having that
conversation you don't understand i
chose you right and so that's they're
they're continually closing that loop um
and some kids do great and some kids
struggle with that i think
i mean that
that's just kind of part of the deal um
that's just part of living in a screwed
up world right a hard hard world but
um
that's been my recommendation to don't
have those hard conversations i can't
answer that question for you on the
psychological state of kids and whatnot
i'm more concerned on this call with
your well-being right now
and you don't sound like you're okay
and you can tell me i'm wrong i'm like
dylan i'm fine i'm doing great
no i i appreciate you saying that
all right
um i say this all the time and sarah i
hope you'll trust me
you are worth being well
and you're worth going to sleep and
you're worth thinking about your past
without your heart rate taking off on
you
and you're worth being loved recklessly
all those things
and i hate hate hate that somebody hurt
you and i hope if your dream is to
become a mom i hope that happens for you
and i hope it happens in the way that
you have a picture
of what that's going to look like and
that you're able to fulfill that picture
and i hope you'll do the hard work of
having hard conversations with people
who are trying to become parents in
non-traditional ways
because that wisdom there is going to be
invaluable
will you call somebody somebody new
i will i will for you
not for me but for you
i will you promise
i promise can i tell you that you're one
of the bravest people i've talked to in
a long time
thank you and when you have a little
baby i want you to send me a photo okay
i will and i also want you to reach back
out and you either email you can um
you you're gonna post a slide into my
dms right i think you're supposed to do
that yeah just send me a direct message
on the internet
um
but
let me know that you called somebody
some a new counselor okay
i will you will today
you're so brave thank you for being
strong thank you thank you thank you
thank you hey we'll be right back
for too long we've avoided the hard
conversations about mental health
relationships and the food we eat and i
don't want it to be true either but it
is the quality and quantity of the food
that we put into our body it matters and
oftentimes we're forced to decide
between cheap food that's good for our
budget or expensive food that's good for
our family but there's a company that
solved the problem greensbury is a
family-owned meat provider working with
farmers and fishermen all over the
country they sell organic grass-fed beef
free-range poultry pork lamb bison and
sustainable seafood their meat is less
expensive than what i can get at the
grocery store right down the street and
they deliver it to my door now listen
i'm a lunatic about meat quality and
this is the stuff i feed my family so go
to
greensbury.com and you'll get 10 off
your first purchase check it out today
your nutrition is worth it
we are
back and let's go to scott in columbus
ohio hey what's up scott
oh not too much how you doing today sir
not too much either man y'all doing well
yeah all right you know this is my lunch
time so you know um always a work kind
of a working lunch well thanks for uh
hanging out with me during your lunch
hour so what's up man how can i help oh
well um
reason calling and i never thought i'd
be doing something like this in my life
or anything like that so i'm more
nervous about that than talking hey
there's three or four businesses that
makes two of us man i sure never thought
i'd be doing this so we're on the same
team oh
so
you know
my wife and i have been married for
about 10 years okay a little over 10
years now
and you know we knew going in that we
were kind of very opposite people
she had a different
she had a lot of stuff going growing up
um you know her dad was alcohol leg she
had you know verbal abuse her mom passed
when she was 12.
and she she struggled with that stuff
early on in her adult life and uh
but she kind of got that under control
and
and for me i you know i get a
pretty good upbringing
and didn't have any of that type of
stuff but i kind of wandered around
myself in my early 20s kicked around all
that stuff
went into the
navy at age 27 all those 18 year olds
thought i was really old
and i know
so i felt like i've had a couple
different lives and
as as uh as the book goes on very cool
and you know in my 40s we met it was my
first marriage um it was her third
marriage uh we got married and you know
we we work pretty well together and
that type of stuff but
um the last few years hasn't been quite
the same and i don't know if it's just
you know our differences kind of
came to a head or we just grew apart a
little bit but um just i'm gonna i wrote
a few things down and that's what i do
when i get ready for
an appointment or something like that
good for you um you know we haven't uh
like i said we were raised very
differently i'm just going to read down
this um
we we haven't been intimated in probably
five or six years we kind of stopped
holding hands three or four years ago
um
by intimate you haven't had sex in four
or five years five or six years
yes okay yes all right um we have we you
know we did a little kiss in the morning
um but we haven't done that in about a
year
um
and just sort of settled into it seems
more like a partnership roommates than
we are
a married couple
um and you know pardon me i'm 55 so it's
kind of like
okay well together we do okay
monetarily wise we we can do stuff and
you know some things we do real well
together but
uh the last few years has been kind of a
challenge because she's
kind of on the opposite uh
political side of it but it's
more than that if it was just that i
mean
if that was a big big thing we would
never have gotten together in the first
place um so i've always kind of been
more in between and
you know open mind i think that's the
best way to go with that type of stuff
but you know i hear you talk a lot about
people diving into the phones being on
the internet and that's to me that's
kind of what she's done it seems like
every
i don't know if you call them conspiracy
theories or anything like that
she considers seems like everything's a
fact i mean just
see if i can read
she spends all all the evening she goes
into the room probably around seven
o'clock and just
listen to her phone and stuff like that
you know she says the president is not
really president the former president's
really the president now the the current
president's never been to the white
house
there's a cabal
controlling everything for the last 20
years
silver is going to go up for four
thousand percent
continue i'm taking notes
i agree with everything continue
okay all right and she started she
started buying bitcoin and with the
the silver um
you know i don't i didn't mind it at the
beginning because it's
not the worst investment it's not the
best investment and no it's the worst
it's the worst yeah it's a terrible
investment terrible and and uh you know
100 100 ounces 200 ounces okay
we could absorb that and this lesson sat
last saturday
and this is actually after i contacted
your show
she told me she finally started to dive
into bitcoin
like
as as as it's collapsing in front of our
very eyes yeah yeah so so then i asked
her and i try to pay attention to a
point but at the same time you know
she's always she she's been kind of more
the bill payer and she does make sure
you know we have money in the bank and
all that type stuff we're paying bills
we can go do this and that
that type of stuff we have no debt uh no
car debt no house debt or anything like
that um so we're doing okay on that but
then i asked her that day because she
knew i was not that happy about the
bitcoin so how much have
because she told me she was going to
stop at 500 ounces and she told me she's
got about 30 000 in silver right now so
that's in the last probably six or seven
months thirty thousand dollars in silver
yeah yeah
yeah so
and
i just told her i said i don't know that
we can keep going like this i said
i i just don't know that i completely
trust her with when it comes to money
absolutely so so like bring me to a head
how can i i help it sounds like there's
a lot here well i'm trying to figure out
you know
now well i guess one thing i want to say
is all that aside say that you took that
out
all that stuff out
part of me
it maybe is ready to move on anyway
because again you know i was telling you
we haven't had sex in five or six years
so that happened before all that so why
what let me back up why did y'all stop
having sex
i don't know
we've never talked about it so why for
five years
have you never brought up to your
wife hey we haven't had sex in
1500 days
i you know i can't can't answer that and
um it's and i'm and i'm kind of a guy
with at work and stuff that i'm always
feeling i can usually find a solution to
things and it's hard for me or maybe
it's right in my face and i'm just
ignoring it and so i thought i'd reach
out and and i am going to
do a little bit more than this i've
already got that surges set up awesome
through our eap program oh that's
awesome good i'm glad you're reaching
out to somebody all right so let me let
me jump in here
first is
i hear a
somewhat of a resignation i'm 55. we're
making good money tired there you go
you're tired
and your body is checked out
another word for that over time is
depression your body's just said i'm out
and something has
begun to stoke the fire a little bit
your body's beginning to feel not safe
because your money is going out the door
now
and so i want you to hear me very very
carefully
you
deserve a
rambunctious
chaotic
hilarious
intimate sex life at the age of 55.
okay
yeah
not i don't really know we haven't had
sex in five or six years and i just
never even never even asked never even
talked about it i just like to find
solutions on my own when i can't find
them i just kind of kind of just move on
brother you're worth more than that
she's worth more than that
right and
you know she said we've had you know a
few discussions with everything and
she's told me that you know maybe she
needs to go find like-minded people and
uh you know
i want to say back like maybe you should
you know yeah
so so and maybe that's maybe that is the
right right
there maybe but me and my wife are
radically different on different things
and i've got friends in my life that
laughingly and lovingly and mockingly
call me their hilarious liberal friend
and i've got friends in my life who are
like oh god here comes dalone he's super
conservative guy
because i've got different thoughts on
different topics and we've just
bifurcated the world in some stupid this
one or that one
my wife does too and we don't match on a
lot
and so there's a few topics in our house
we have agreed to not talk about
there are some topics that um
not be just because we i i know if i go
down this road we're just i'm just doing
it to start a fight and what a dumb way
to live
and i know what her thoughts are on it
and so i love her she's my wife we're
raising a family together she's my best
friend like all these things i don't
have to agree with her on this
especially when she's clearly wrong
right
and she would be telling you the same
thing like especially when he's clearly
wrong
but that doesn't impact our desire to
be together
and here's the big difference we share
the same values we just have different
beliefs
and one of our values is we will honor
each other and one of our values is
we're going to be really curious
and another one of our values is we're
not going to pick fights just to pick
fights stupid
and so i have people in my life
some that bernie sanders would be like
that's a little bit far to the left you
should probably reign it in and i've got
other friends in my life who have slept
in my house um who've shared my home
that have eaten at my table whose kids
played with my kids
who would make trump be like that's a
little bit too far to the right let's
let's wind it back a little bit right i
love that about my life
and so having different beliefs and
different like man
what an awesome way to live so the fact
that y'all are
in different camps have different ideas
like she thinks cove is a hoax and
there's some guy in the back of his
trunk with a youtube channel he's like
for the real truth right and
fine and that what is it biden's like on
a spaceship or something whatever dude
that's fantastic
um there's a way that that happens in a
relationship and it's hilarious
it's funny
and then there's a way where that type
of going down rabbit holes one way or
going down rabbit holes the other way
or a better way to say it is she goes in
at seven o'clock during what would
normally be her intimate time
and her body's screaming for connection
and that's where she finds connection as
with she's created she's curated and the
internet has helped her with its
algorithms curate
a group of like-minded people who keep
her safe because at home she's got no
one
and you've done the same thing
you're tired and quite frankly it sounds
like you're lonely and i've been there
too
okay
all of this starts with two things
number one you being really really
honest with yourself about these two
questions
what do i want
and
what do i need
and when you answer the need questions
this was a game changer in my house
i need physical touch that's something
that settles my body down for a number
of reasons
and my wife is not a physical touchy
kind of person
but she'll hold my hand
she'll put her bare foot on my bare foot
under a table
not in some pervy porny way but in a
subtly way
okay
and she will put her arm on my shoulder
while i'm scrubbing the dishes and she's
grabbing something on the dishwasher
right and i am loud as i'll get out in
the mornings i wake up just ready to go
go set the world on fire and she needs
quiet in the morning and so i'm quiet
because i love her and respect her
because i spoke my needs out loud she
spoke her needs out loud and we've got
lists of our needs right all that to say
is
you need to be clear about what you need
and then the hard part which you may
need to get a counselor you may need to
have a hard conversation with your wife
is
honey here's what i need
and what are your needs
when's the last time you all went out
and just had breakfast together and just
said hey what are the let's what are the
state of things
i love you and i miss you have you all
ever done that
no not that we i mean we go we've gone
out to breakfast and that type of stuff
but you know we our our
talks have not been the same the last
couple years as they used to be yeah and
here's the thing we used to be all drunk
go on a trip without without ever
turning on the radio because we would
talk the whole time so don't do that
anymore okay so
what you're mentioning we're roommates
we're just
co household managers
is one of the most common
things that's going on in the country
right now in marriages so you're not
alone
covet has destroyed the intimacy people
just got to got busy getting to work
and then they didn't have friends they
didn't have their normal routines they
didn't have the trips
um it was not as fun having sex because
i see you all day every day like the
intimacy and the i don't have anything
to build up all day so i'm just well
whatever just go to bed turned into
let's just watch netflix which turned
into let's just watch youtube which
turned into oh my gosh did you know that
biden is a space alien right and now
we're
done a rabbit hole somewhere
and so
it really starts with everybody saying
hey i want to wind this back and i miss
you
i miss your body i miss your touch i
miss our intimate connection i miss our
laughter i miss our talks and i feel
like
um
that you are in fight or flight you're
not safe that your community found
online is keeping you safe and hear her
i feel like you've just given up on our
relationship i feel like you checked out
i feel like you just go home and watch
tv and put your feet up and have dinner
and
i just go into my bedroom and you don't
follow me
whatever that looks like and i can see
both sides i can see her saying we
haven't had sex for five years husband
and you haven't asked me about it once
and i can also see
honey we haven't had sex for five years
because you've been dating your
um
cell phone
or you've been dating youtube for the
last five years whatever the thing is
hear me say this um
you're worth more than this she's worth
more than this your marriage is worth
more than this and i don't think your
marriage is over if you don't want it to
be but it's going to take some hard
conversations by some grown adults
i'm gonna send you all three
all three questions for humans okay um
what they are it's for when people have
lost connection it's a deck of cards i
made up man they're nothing special i'm
actually pretty cool but
it's a three decks of cards
and i'm going to send them to you i'm
also going to send you my new book i
want you to read it together okay own
your past change the future i'm gonna
send that to you too um cause both of
y'all got some stuff going on and both
of you have gotten off of the path that
y'all were supposed to be taking
together this book will help you get
back but these these three decks of
cards questions for humans
it's just gonna help man it's gonna be
something to reintroduce conversation
together it's gonna reintroduce intimacy
together
um the deck for for couples the deck for
folks who are like you who are married
and kind of gotten off
man
merry christmas this deck will help you
come back together if you'll allow it to
okay
i want you to use this stuff
and i want you to be ready to have hard
conversations but before you do
what do you need
and what do you want scott you're a
brave man thanks for calling i know this
is hard man i know you're tired tired
tired
i want you to tell you that you're worth
getting back up dust your knees off dust
your shoulders up get some people around
you
let's get back into this thing man
you're worth more than this we'll be
right back
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between
and there is one thread that weaves
through all of these different people
that you
me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships
i'm talking relationships where you can
be yourself share hard things and know
you'll show up for one another in my new
book own your past change your future
we'll walk through a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and getting connected
because it's a key part of living a good
life you'll learn why shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous you'll even
learn how to start making real friends
so go to johndaloney.com to take the
next step towards wellness that's own
your past change your future at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show the song of the day man one
of my favorites is off the southern
harmony and musical companion record out
in 1992 making me feel like i'm a
thousand years old it's by the great
black crows and the song is called
sometimes salvation and it goes like
this
to lessen my troubles i stopped hanging
out with vultures and empty saviors like
you i wish i had a nickel
for every miracle that you easily
tricked me into you can lead a horse to
water but faith is another matter so
don't you surrender because sometimes
salvation comes in the eye of the storm
of no time for accusations or
conversations on all the bad bad things
you do
just a note from your jailer drugs and
their relations to all the people around
you i've kept secret your superstitions
and on all its twisted wisdom that i
fell into sister
can you try and find me
that's what we're doing here man i'm
trying to find you we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode if your
milkshake brings all the boys to the
yard i'm glad you're with us my whole
life i've had this narrative for my
mother
that my father who has you know he
passed away my husband was at work and
he got
a call from a stranger turns out he is
claiming to be my father
whoa
i'm struggling in relationships with
friendship and i get all the time people
saying giselle you're way too nice you
don't speak up you don't say what's on
your mind and i just feel paralyzed they
are more of the type of people that like
to hit up every happy hour every day
[Music]